alright um marked an check I'm with
evolved analytics and we have a software
product for data analysis data modeler
which we license as well as doing
consulting and related projects in that
space so one of the things of course
data science and and you know big data
this is the theme but the reality is
that the information content on data
sets is generally you know there's a lot
of value beginning from relatively small
save million arrests less records you
know hundreds of variables or fewer okay
so if you get into the modeling space if
you know that the system is linear and
you know that it you know its structure
then you want to use linear regression
because that's right technology for the
situation if you know the model
structure and its nonlinear but you do
know the model structure then of course
it's a nonlinear regression of parameter
estimation sort of scenario the big
focus of machine learning is where I
know which variables count and I know
but i don't know the model structure
that's sort of an open-ended analysis
and very powerful you're you're looking
at a lot of tools their neural Nets
support vector machines random forests
and also symbolic regression which is
the technology I care about but our
sweet spot for us is you just basically
don't know anything you have this big
pile of data and you know what's what's
truth in that there you really want to
be using symbolic regression now you
know I have a bit of frustration because
oftentimes you know the the drunk are
looking for his keys under the light
where they're the lights good right not
necessarily look and where the keys are
good
one thing that's also important in the
in the overall modeling process is it's
a workflow it's an iterative process to
look at what counts okay and and then
you deploy the model maintain the model
and if you just do one part of it you're
not really doing what needs to be done
data in the real world is is typically
ugly because you've got correlated
variables lots of Records maybe you have
a fat data array and we've got clients
with which are doing modeling with
25,000 variables I could have long
records we've got you know NIST is doing
rheology modeling with you know millions
of Records and and hundreds of molecular
descriptors you've got erroneous data
you've got missing date all these things
sort of have to be handled automatically
so the key point here as we go through
is that symbolic regression is really a
hypothesis generator we you know the
conventional strategy in in statistics
is to propose a hypothesis see how well
it fits and if it's not good enough that
you propose another hypothesis well that
loop is very human intensive and it also
imposes restrictions because
unfortunately God doesn't know that the
world is the second-order polynomial
with no cross terms so what we're going
to do is we're going to have this
primordial soup i'm going to throw into
this VAT the data and some operators you
know plus x square root whatever and let
it let it evolve and then we're going to
get lots of solutions lots of hypotheses
generated and and have come out okay so
for this analysis just i'll be using a
chemical reactor data sanitize from the
consulting project we did it was they
were having problems with the quality
control metric and so we have 125
variables three months worth of data to
data sources one was the gas
chromatography from grab samples so that
the chemist care
about that because it gives them insight
and turns of what's going on the
production engineers have the p.i system
the process information system and you
know that's useful from the perspective
of what to do so on that note we're
going to shift over launch the GUI so we
have a notebook interface that we
developed so as standard function
package so this is useful to assemble
custom workflows but we started we a
couple years ago started working on a on
a GUI because of the inability of people
to actually hit shift enter and and and
you know truth be known I've come to
prefer it as an interface because you
know it just you winds up being this
interactive you're bouncing around
through the data here's the here's the
data let's go take a look at at these
characteristics the the data summary
table sort of lets me look at
characteristics on an individual basis
how numeric it is you know of course you
need to be able to plot stuff and here
it's go 125 little plots there the data
completeness map lets me lets me look
and say how complete is in this case I
have some missing data in a few
non-numeric columns but the the real
thing here is the correlation chart and
this is the thing the bugaboo because
you know your conventional assumption is
that you've got uncorrelated inputs
right and you have to be able to deal
with all this stuff in blue dark blue
dark red or the you know highly
correlated or highly anti-correlated and
you have to be able to handle that stuff
so what we do I'll just do a quick about
30 second modeling I've got some
redundant variables in there you can see
here that you can add comments to your
to your modeling round so this is one of
the things your iterative you want it's
your slowly attacking truth you might
take those 125 variables and I'm going
to I'm going to chip chip away at that
and try to develop understanding and
insight as I go so what was what I've
just done is of initiated a one-minute
modeling run and what you see here is
going to be for traces because this is a
quad core laptop and so it your each
model search runs independently so so
you spawn off these sub kernels and they
go I'm going to got clients running as
many as 200 sub kernels simultaneously
doing doing model searches but which is
what you're seeing then is is very you
know algebraic model so human interpreta
balada and that's and that's one of the
the advantages here is you're able to
say I can I can mind I've got all these
models but now I can go in and mind them
and what we're doing here is this this
plot here is is air 1 minus R squared
and complexity so rewarding during this
evolutionary search what's a good model
a good model is simple and it's accurate
so we really the constraint that we're
throwing on into the process and it's
it's chip when weight that in what
you've seen here this should in this
trace very short chase is over time good
models get rewarded and you're and
you're building up in an interface so
let's analyze some models
so I've got 32 to modeling runs that I'm
going to load and and what we see here
is is this trade-off now this this point
here is the the knee of the pareto
friend is what we call it so this is the
this is sort of the sweet spot of where
I want to develop models but let's take
a look at some some other tools so so
there's what 4000 some models that we
had done with you know a whole bunch of
three minute modeling runs so the model
dimensionality table is is important
because it's telling me how many
variables do I need for a model and it'd
be up ok so here let's make this a
little larger so you can see it
so we've got it masseur to got this
distribution of of models so where's
where is the sweet spot well the problem
is you know in this case I was looking
at all the variables but I really you
know I want something with a hundred
complexity of no more than one hundred
and seventy percent are R squared and
and I'm going to sit here and take so
you know this models up here in the
upper right-hand corner I don't really
care about them some of it I'm going to
trim off and take fifty percent of the
models closest to the pareto front okay
and that could be sort of this banded
structure and these are the ones are
sort of interesting I can explore now I
can come back to say well you know for
my candidate models where's my action
and now now this here is you know
someplace between three and five models
is sort of three to five variables in my
models sort of be a handy place to be I
can look at you know this is looking in
at various combinations I can sort of
mouse over and and see see what sort of
models have been developed in there
remember we start with 125 variables so
it's you know it's reasonably impressive
that you can chip this thing down in in
such an efficient manner I can look at
my variable presence so this is you know
which ones have emerged to the fore you
get you know it's you know even though
we've started off with all these really
correlated inputs you know we've focused
very quickly now each of the model
searches has has followed its own path
so we do get different
results so that what this is doing is
breaking breaking the modeling into its
independent searches and and saying how
prevalent is a given variable in that
modeling run so we're getting an idea of
substitution effect so what's the
potential is / for replacement because
when you're doing something going into a
plant I may have I have choices of
sensors I mean is a tent as a pressure
sensor more reliable than a temperature
sensor probably not but you know so I've
got I've got different things or I can
use a grab sample in this case I've got
a mixture of of GC measurements and
things well grab sample that's you know
a few hour delayed get that data in here
would I rather have something that i can
use directly okay so let's hop forward
and retrieve I did did some modeling
turn that off this modeling then
strictly focused on the gas
chromatography information for the
chemists sake
that should
ok
so
here I'm I'm going to look at this at
this information again the the model
dimensionality is is tell me is sort of
trade-offs I want to go ok so here we
you know so so back to the mall you know
so here's the substitution effects that
I go so three variable models I can use
may be small GGC for now and of course
in the with the real data this would
actually be the chemical name that would
pop up it's extracted from the file you
know but I but this is how i can look at
variables i can go in then i can take
this variable set and i can i can mine
it because it's a algebraic structure
now in the evolutionary search with what
happens is is a nugget will happen it
may be the difference of two variables
the ratio of two variables some sort of
structure and this structure adds value
and the value that gets added then is
you know is gives you insight saying oh
that's you know that's an interesting
relationship what does that mean this is
where these were extracting insight so
but what i can do then is i can say you
know the difference between chemical 44
and chemical fifty i'm going to add that
as a meta variable and so that then
appears in the generate models i can
select have these meta variables i can
use essentially as nuggets as structures
in subsequent modeling rounds and say do
they reply and what's the value the
other thing that
that I can do is I can look at variable
combinations and let's for that let's go
to Round six Erica so go go look at
what's available for the process side of
the world
and the variable all right so here here
we're looking at oops loaded the wrong
data set oh yeah if I if I can read that
would help
alright so we've got you know different
models model sets that have i've got
been you know say say let's let's look
at our model so variable presence chart
so what I can do here though just just
as an aside I can go in and set a
threshold of saying I want I want to
look at I want to focus in on variables
which are in at least twenty percent of
the models and then I can name that as a
named variable set and then exploit that
in in either modeling where I'm focusing
in on those variables during this the
model search or filter directly based on
those but what I want to do first here
just is variable combination table and
I'm going to I'm going to sit there and
say I want to restrict things two models
with no more than four variables okay
what what what is my impact of having
those variables are their combinations
that I might want to use an explorer and
and go forward and and here you're
seeing the source and a couple
temperatures and and and it's oftentimes
you'll you'll see something interesting
there and want to build build off that
very small subset now let's move let's
move to
sort of the end game and I'm going to
load in I did a bunch of modeling with
with only four variables so really foot
really chop this down I got four
variables that I think that i think are
candidates and you know this is where
the plant engineers come through and and
you know have preferences on what they'd
like so how how good are these models
well I can I've got a couple options
here I can discard the model picker on
so the model Picard lets me select a
model from that's been developed and and
sort of look at its attributes you know
so here's here's you know most most
people would choose a model now we don't
want to choose a model because because
we've got all this diversity we've got
out this whole really different world
views of the data we can exploit that
and and build an ensemble of trustable
models so we can take this whole whole
collection of they're all good right
there all candidates in the sense that
they're simple they're accurate they're
meeting our thresholds in that fashion
let's get a diverse set of them and and
get get a diverse set and then and then
they're going together there when they
when they see date that spot and
parameter space where they've had
experience they're going to agree
because they're all good and trusted
however when they're exposed to new
regions of parameter space or the the
target system has changed in some
fashion then they're going to diverge
because we've chosen them to be be be
unique but sorry how you can have the
standard sort of issue prediction plots
of of models and and trade-offs but
let's let's go to this ensemble that
with that i've defined that's just
clicking a button to get that the
ensemble prediction plot then is
prediction of truth versus reality now
what you see there are error bars around
each prediction point so you get the
sort of spread that's that's coming into
play if we use the response plot x
lor now we're now we've got is you know
from given point in parameter space so
high dimensional parameter space I can
sit there and say what is what is the
effect of changing variables relative to
that space now here we've got two
temperatures and you know they're you
know in a distillation column there
couple right so we have you know couple
variables so if I start changing
temperature 20 so you know now I've got
my tray my my tray you know in a
different spot now what you've seen here
is at that point in parameter space now
I've got uncertainty that's been
introduced in my model if temperature 22
starts riding up getting back to its
sort of natural alignment then that
uncertainty goes away sometimes we're
we're getting this trust ability factor
that's that's very important now just
about out of time I will say then that
what another thing that you can do
that's very important it's not it's not
in the GUI but it's it's used by number
of folks for for using the notebook
interface is I can take that trust
ability and say I'm going to do active
design of experiments so I've got this
sort of i've got a difficult to major
system i'm going to i'm going to go in
and take a handful of data part start
building i'll start saying which which
factors are important so you know
example is catalyst discovery i'm going
to take a blob expand it into its 2,000
molecular descriptors which descriptors
are mattering for the the performance
that I care about and then I can go in
and say okay this is where I think
there's an optimum go explore that
region parameters basis or standard
optimization strategy but what I can
also do is take my ensemble and say
where they disagree because where they
disagree is where is the most valuable
next nugget
information I can collect and so that is
is you know very key to this act of
design of experiments and so now you're
now you're covering your adaptively
sampling your operating regime and
really trying to nail things down